Cobin 19 has affected nearly every part
of our lives and has made things
particularly difficult for certain
populations of people when the pandemic
forced us all inside it also boxed in
victims of domestic abuse and caused a
spike in assistance calls now as our
country recovers it's more important
than ever to support agencies that help
those victims like safeness if CEO Liz
Orton Berger joins us now with more
highly as we spoke a few weeks into the
pandemic how have things changed or
progressed since that time right so
right along the timeline and the
utilization rates that we would have
expected we saw a steady increase during
the shutdown and then a huge spike after
the stay at home order was lifted and
may actually marked the largest month of
intakes to our shelter that we've ever
had in our forty three year history so
it is it has been stretched all of our
resources and now we're starting to see
that flow through other program areas as
well including our counseling and
advocacy programs Wow the largest in 43
years and how has funding been going to
this time and so the community has been
incredibly generous and there have been
extra pots of money that have come out
of the federal government but our
biggest concern has been marriage
license funding so within the state of
Nevada a small portion of marriage
license funding is set aside for
domestic violence and sexual assault
agencies and of course given the
shutdown that marriage license fund is
all but depleted and so as a state that
fund will be which is typically three
million dollars will only be 1 million
dollars next year money but to agencies
like safeness it's a critical glue for
the services that aren't funded in other
places including marketing and awareness
campaigns money so how can we you have a
fundraiser coming up at the end of the
month and what are you also hoping to
get from lawmakers as they respond to
this crisis right so we would like
lawmakers to understand that during this
time of Kogut its your DV agencies and
section
Sault agencies that have stood up and
taken care of victims we have expanded
services we have literally answered the
call day and night through our hotline
to make sure that our community is safe
now the stay-at-home order is lifted and
we're moving through the phases of
coming back more and more victims are
going to be coming out of their
environments for help and support to get
out of their domestic violence
relationships this is not a time for us
to decrease funding at the time for us
to be at least made whole as for what
we're doing because we are not limiting
or decreasing services so we need
lawmakers to fight for the marriage
license fund to be made whole for 2020
2021 so that we can continue to do this
work okay and Liz with 15 seconds left
tell us about the statewide fundraiser
on June 26th please yes so you can put a
safeness org and donate on June 26 to
the campaign to help rebuild the
marriage license fund so that agencies
like ours can keep doing this well thank
you so much we greatly appreciate your
input please be safe and we know we'll
touch base with you again thank you so
thank you